[Music]
Runk hey yo what's up man you guys it is
congratulations time but first let me
just say I'm going to be in Houston dude
what I'm be in Houston I uh have a I'm
opening up ticket well I have another
show in Sacramento so here's the deal
look I got Sacramento coming up uh Brea
impra let me just go through it
chronologically here
Sacramento January 13th at the Crest
theater I just added another show
because the first one sold out then I'm
going to be in Brea California working
some
material uh and I'll be in Phoenix at
That Celebrity Theater which is like one
of my favorites it's in the round El
Paso Albuquerque these are all coming up
Colona BC Vancouver I added a show had a
show sell out added a show uh Rochester
New York kitner Ontario shareport and
then Houston and Corpus Christi and I
got a bunch of other ones go to
chris.com um I'm updating my schedule
always so go to chris.com go to
chris.com to get the merch the grower
die special also is out there um thank
you to everyone that has seen the
special it's my proudest work I
appreciate you if you haven't seen it
yet go to chris.com and get the special
grow or die uh and get some merch while
you're there dude um and that is that
and this is
[Music]
congratulations
uh it is the new year and right now as
we
are filming this it is January 1 so
congratulations
2024 we are here and ready I will be 44
this year and that is absolutely crazy
to me um I don't feel old but you know I
was in my I was at the gym today and I
was like you know what dude I feel like
uh I was doing this thing where I was
like I don't like the there was
something I I was thinking in my head
like I don't like that and then I was
like that's an I'm an old guy I guess
you know like I guess that's am i g to
be 44 this year that's crazy I forget my
age a lot actually um but uh yeah so
anyway it's the New Year's don't have a
resolution it's the new year not the New
Year's I don't like when people well
it's New Year's Day so you can say it
anyway um did some shows last night at
the LA Factory it was great uh and um
you know I gotta say
dude West Hollywood Hollywood
La I it's always been my favorite place
to perform because of um it's hard to
perform in LA because the crowds could
do anything they they they it's not even
like they're choosing to go see a comedy
show it's like they just happened to
show up at a comedy show because they
could go do anything else they could go
to Saddle Ranch down the street they
could go see you know just countless
musicians in town they can go to the
Troubador they could go to the Magic
Castle they could you know um so I
always
liked doing shows in LA because I feel
like in a way if you can you know the
Crowds Are jaded they've seen they saw
they saw John Mayor drive by on the way
into the comedy show right so it's
like so I I I I uh but so I've been
doing material and I've been working on
my material because I've got you know
I'm on tour now doing new material not
which is different from grow or die so
if you've seen the special you can still
come out but um
I I was I I I'm definitely free talking
about whatever I want like there's a lot
of like I I'm I say things that I truly
feel and believe and and you know it's
the reason why I can do that now is
because I'm free I don't I I can't be
cancelled right and that's a beautiful
thing because I
already I I faced that fire and I can
say whatever I want so I do I do I'm I'm
being authentic and 100% me and and
because of that I say whatever the [__]
I want and I
feel pockets of Kickback in La like
because of how la la is um you know I
can feel when I'm doing certain things
and saying things that you sh you know
uh that don't you know that that fly
very well in the north of Florida that
that we like you know the general
population like but but there's always
those po cuz like that whole thing and I
don't want I don't want to talk about
you know I hate talk getting talk about
being woke and can't like all of it is
just so it feels like it's p a at this
point but um there are Parts I I could
feel like one or two people go like oh
like when I say certain things
and
man it makes me feel alive dude I drill
harder your boys got to drill harder so
um it is what it is my
babies but it feels good to be free bro
I look at some other comedians that are
doing
stuff there are some great comedians out
there that are pushing the envelope and
I don't think by the way the goal should
not be to push the envelope it should be
to be funny right like there's comedians
that are userfriendly
that are fantastic very talented and
some of my favorite comedians and then
there are guys that you know push the
envelope that are also very fantastic
but um there are comedians that are
just I don't know man I guess I I guess
I kind
of I always thought I was going to you
know there's no way I would have made it
through any of this stuff without like
cancel stuff without like I say I would
eventually say something and then
somebody I would lose everything so you
know obviously that happened anyway but
like I feel I feel good it's 2024 and I
feel good I guess that's what I'm trying
to say I don't even know um
but I don't have a resolution somebody
asked me what my resolution is I said I
don't have one I went on the way to the
gym I was walking on my way to the gym
and the lady said do you have what's
your resolution I said you know what I
don't really do that and I felt like wow
I'm annoying I'm an annoying guy right
because an annoying person wants to let
you know what type of guy they are right
or like what type of
chick they are like this is what an
annoying guy says um
um uh hey
dude I'm not a dick I'm just telling the
truth I'm just truthful hey guy you
don't you can be truthful and not be a
DI
right
um but you yeah or like a like a like
sorry I'm not a [__] if you don't like
the truth then you know it's like it's
like no dude you're a [__] okay um but
so she was like what's your resolution I
was like I don't really do that and I
was like oh [__] not corny and I was
like I just got to I don't you know I
I'm just going to keep doing my thing
I'm going to keep going keep going dude
keep doing what you're doing man if you
if your New Year's resolution is to do
something drastically different you're
already [__] up you need to implement
that [__] ah dude what is this a health
and Wellness podcast dude I'm not is
this a [__] am I an am I a [__] uh
what do you call it influencer yeah
maybe I don't
know do I influence maybe I don't
know my point is just keep going some of
you are going to be 44 this year just
keep going but I feel good man I feel
nice was doing [__] my back and my
[__] chest today what the hell he
didn't even hit legs dude he hits legs
all the times he even hit legs it's
like
um a lot of stuff I I think happened in
my life uh in this past week let's the
the Christmas I talked about Christmas a
little bit
um dude Calvin holy
Christ Kristen was out of town for two
nights she went to the Bowl game all
right I don't know what the bowl game is
in Dallas the toilet ball or whatever
the [__] it is and um she went and it
was mizou versus whoever the hell they
played and where's my Park guys here and
um
dude
so I was alone with Cal my mother-in-law
was in town but I was alone with Calvin
meaning I put him to bed and I was also
alone in the bed sleeping okay now for
for some reason sleeping alone in my
bed I don't know what it is but it's
it's so hard to go to sleep BEC and I I
think it's that thing like when my wife
is not in my in our
bed in my bedroom I have this thought
where it's like
man I got this bed I could do anything
why don't I build a castle in here you
know what I mean like just like idiot
dude stuff
and then you know what I do nothing I
just wait in bed till I go to sleep
right but like I'll get in I'll be like
maybe I'll bring chips in here I don't
even eat chips you know dude I got to
get fun dip you know like just dumb
dummy [__] like let's watch porn on the
TV and I don't I've never done that
right not saying I don't watch porn but
like on the TV Dude I you know what I'll
do AirPlay
BJs
right and then I just go I have that
thought and then I just go
and then I just wait and play like Royal
match on my phone until I fall asleep
right so I put Calvin to
bed I I I went to go do a a show I
believe and then I came back because you
know my mother-in-law was
here and
uh I come back I'm about to pass
out and I hear my son
scream my mother-in-law's name which he
calls her Kiki that's not her name
because she's
not you know a stripper from Fort
Lauderdale but she he calls her Kiki and
he says Kiki and I run out and I say
Calvin what's up and he says and he's
like H he comes in my
bed and he I said are you okay buddy did
you have a bad dream and he say yeah I
said what was your dream he said I was
sweating I was sweating sweating I was
sweating trying to get to Mom I kept on
sweating trying to get to Mom and I
couldn't get her and Mom got away and I
was like oh man that's so sad you know
it
sounds fine but you know you know how
dreams can be nightmares and they're not
nothing bad H you know what I'm saying
like you could be like you could have a
a the scariest dream ever and it's just
a it's really just your man I was in
Radio Shack and dude it was crazy the
guy was like he kept asking me questions
about VCRs and it was like I didn't
really know the answer and then he was
like I'll go into the back come with me
and we went to the back and there were
like a bunch of [__]
electronics and you're like and and
you're talking it telling about this
nightmare and you're like telling some
guy and you're like guy's like oh yeah
that's not scary that's so boring that
don't tell me that you [__] loser hey
stop wasting my you just told me about
an
errand so my my son said that and I was
like H I guess it's kind of scary if
you're almost four you can't find your
mom and you're sledding why you sledding
my you
know so I'm like oh that's that's it's
all good buddy it's fake I'm with you
right now I got you we go to sleep right
so but I didn't even go to sleep yet so
it's 3:30 now and I'm like man I haven't
gone to sleep
yet he wakes up at 4:30 so now 1 hour
later I finally get to sleep now I'm up
and he goes dude he this is what he does
sits up in bed and I feel it like I'm a
light I'm sleeping light and I look over
and my son who's almost
four the scariest of the horror movie
age for kids when they're in movies and
demonic points to
nothing and says hey
Dad who's that
guy ch
s but I bury it and why do I bury it
because I'm
dad now am I scared no I'm terrified but
I'm neither scared or terrified right
now because I've got to swallow it and
I'm dad right say he said who's that guy
and I go no one's there and ran out and
jumped into the pool my son traumatized
and and knows I'm a [__] all right so I
immediately swallowed it I'm not scared
or terrified I'm
dad so I say what guy and he says that
guy over there and I said
Calvin nobody's over there and he says
yes there
is Terror but I bury it cuz I'm dad and
I say well
what do you mean cuz there's nobody over
there and he says yeah there's a guy
over there he's like talking
oh hey [__] get back up in my
anus I say
oh what's he saying and he says he's
talking and he's kind of doing like this
and then my son goes like
this so not
only is it
scary
that my son thinks there's someone in my
room that I don't see that's doing
this but I'm also staring at an almost
four-year-old doing
this
nothing's
scarier okay so now I say oh well he's
not doing that and you're just
dreaming it's all good I got you get
back to sleep now he go lays down I hold
him but I'm like I kind of need
to I'm
scared
[__] get back up in that anus
and then I woke you know I had to wake
up after that like 8:30 because Billy
got up dude it
was it
was it was terrifying hey dude hey
Calvin if you're watching this when
you're older thanks for that but by the
way I protected you didn't I and I said
I would and I you know I protected you
against nothing but it's nothing was
there but what if kids get are like in a
can see in a secret Dimension like dogs
can you know and they see ghosts right I
don't believe in that [__] but I'm just
saying like there's no ghosts dude I'm
so it's so annoying that people think
that ghosts are real and stuff like that
is real because I'm not even saying it's
not real if it is real show me all good
I'm 40 almost four show me and I'll
believe it you didn't yet okay see
you I am getting old though because I
[__] ate uh no not ate I was
God this is actually so Emar whatever
who gives a [__] it's not embarrassing I
don't get embarrassed at this kind of
stuff I should I say it's embarrassing
because it should be embarrassing but
it's
not I I was I was sick I told you I was
sick uh last time I think yeah I did and
um I was like 10% sick for like two two
weeks and the the last part was like a
stomach thing and my son I just go I
come out downstairs and I'm like oh I
got a I got a
toot nothing's better than tooting in
front of a three-year-old right you I'm
going to get like a standing ovation
like I'm just so happy I can't wait I
got this toot locked right so I run over
I say yo Calvin and he says what I lift
up my leg and I go to blast out the
toot no sound no to comes out and that's
a real bummer but the even worse bummer
is I [__] my
pants okay so not only did I not get the
laugh the sound didn't come
out and I [__] in my pants with my leg
up all right like dude one like one
thing if you are [__] in your pants
standing that's embarrassing bro I
[__] lifted a leg up like I was a
Powerpuff Girl One are those things like
I was just and then just Powderpuff p p
Powerpuff dude and I and I go oh I'll be
right
back dude this is how it looked I go hey
Calvin lifted a leg up and I said I'll
be right back dude he had no idea that I
just
low what a
bummer huh dude and I'm talking about it
wasn't like the kind where you have to
go and wipe it and you can wear the same
underwear I had to
change like dude I went back upstairs
walked into my room and I was a man
changing his shitty
underwear dude do you
understand and and the best part my son
had no idea any of that happen he didn't
even know I tried to fart he just
thought I lifted a leg up and then said
I'll be right
back how
amazing and then I forgot and here's the
best part cuz our Nanny was there when
it happened I
forgot that I didn't tell them it
happened and then later on I was telling
my wife about it and my nanny heard me
and said oh you [__] yourself then
and I said oh yeah I forgot I didn't I
guess I didn't tell you
dude the best
dad
um it's just really great you
know what does this mean I sometimes I
write [__] down I've got no idea poo poo
with the scent thing in my eye babe what
does that mean
do you
know do you know was it poo poo with the
scent thing in my eye
poooo with the scent thing in my eye
scent thing like smelling
scent scent thing in my eye I don't know
did you get something in your eye I got
something in my eye I guess it was poo
poo I don't know I thought going have
pink eye I don't remember anyway
um dude I I I I I know that sometimes I
talk about being a dad too much but it
is
fullon the the greatest thing dude it's
fullon the greatest thing you know how
they say do the try to get to a point
where you're do where what you love
becomes your job and get paid for that I
did that with stand-up comedy bro now I
need to get paid for being a
dad cuz that's what I love so in a way
that is what I'm doing cuz I'm talking
about being a dad so it all kind of
works out but dude
I we were at we went to cir
Dole
which is in uh was in um Phoenix we went
to Phoenix went to cir to now when I was
a kid I went to cir do solle and I
remember dude I'm not a guy I have a
thing where I'm not impressed by
something that is as impressive as it
can
be I'm not very impressed with something
that
only uh ends up fueling itself right
like this is hard to explain but like
break dancing or or beatboxing is is
like a number one thing it's like as
good as you are at beatboxing the only
thing that that means is you're a good
beatboxer it doesn't help with anything
else you know break dancing is kind of
like that but you could argue it's good
exercise so it kind of falls to the
Wayside in that way but like stuff like
that I I don't like sports is kind of
like that except for it helps you be
more capable hand ey coordination so but
it's one of the reasons why I don't like
sports but beatboxing number one thing
like that okay cir do solle is kind of
in that area because I get it you're
twisting twirling plates around and
you're a human pretzel and you're
jumping off a high dive but then I'm
like who cares you still got to to go
get groceries after that you know you
still got to wipe off all your Kabuki
[__] and then go do your life and I
understand that's your passion that's
what you love and look people flock to
it so that's great do it but it's not
for me all right it's not for me
so of course my wife and her side of the
family say let's go to
Cirus and I think huh I don't love cir
dle but I would love to take my kids to
cir D now Billy's too young so we took
Calvin we all went all the family her
and uh you know Kiki and all everybody
in her family there were like so many
people there in her
family a lot of people in her fil you'd
think she was a Mormon and we get to
ciray and we're watching it and Calvin
is good at watching stuff dude like real
good like not all over the seat you know
for 40 minutes he'll he'll he'll bang it
out and then when that 41st minute hits
he go he'll he will he will look at me
no matter what we're watching and he
will and no matter how many people are
around and he will very loudly say let's
leave okay so that happened right they
were doing some twirly things and I it's
impressive it is impressive but I don't
care in in in the back of my head I'm
I'm watching these dudes jump over each
other and I'm like that's cool but
there's something else huh there's
something else for your life huh no I'm
glad you like it figure something else
out right you're still young you got
your whole life ahead of you stop
jumping over that guy right
ah um so I leave with Calvin because
everyone's not going to leave and he's
like let's leave so I'm like all right
come on let's
go dude my I have a video of it and I'll
I'll send it to you so you can put it in
the
thing but
uh there's these big promo posters of
like
uh things that are coming to the theater
I played the theater before it used to
be the cerica theater now it's something
it's not called that anymore but um and
uh my son said stops and looks up at
this promo this poster that is I don't
see what he's looking at but he's just
like and I'm I'm like it must be like
Bluey or Blues Clues or that guy that
got in trouble for [__] on another
guy that used to be the what was it
um uh what's that
guy uh Hey guys come on let's go look at
the Margo round or the [__] science
what the [__] is his name blippy he's
[__] on another guy yeah and they had to
replace
him yeah he got canceled for [__] on
another guy so they got a mixed race
blippy
now and uh if you're white you can't
[__] on another guy even if it's [__]
all you know on the
level uh now by the way because that
happened now I'm a blippy fan I didn't
give a [__] about him at all but he
straight up [__] on another dude and the
video got out and he got fired at blippy
which sucks dude my heart goes up to
that dude but whatever anyway
um he is
enveloped in this poster I look at the
poster and it's
just for Rob Schneider's show coming to
the his standup show like I'm I'm
talking about my son is like locked into
it and it's just a picture of Rob
Schneider and he's like
this and it's like narcissist whatever
the show's called
narcissist confessions narcissist
confessions I think it's called and my
son says I don't see that and I say you
want to see this and he says yeah I want
to see that and I said well I mean I can
make it happen if you want you know I
know obviously I know Rob and [__] and
like I like that's hilarious my son I
told him his name was Rob schneer my
son wouldn't shut the [__] up about Rob
Schneider for the next
okay on the way home she he's like I
see dude rolling the car he's just like
I see Rob
Snider bro dude can we when we get home
can we see YouTube can we look up on
YouTube Rob Schneider can we see Rob
Schneider uh videos and I'm just like
buddy you're not going to like it like I
don't know what he thinks it is but he
kept and then we were and then later on
when we got home like what's your
favorite part cirto he was like it was
when the guy with the hat
and it was the guy with the hat that
poster dude it was the guy with the hat
and he's and he's uh with
the with the hat and he's talking and
we're like What [__] part is that and
he was like you know I said you mean the
the person in on stage he said no no on
the poster he's talking about [__]
Rob Schneider dude the poster of Rob
Schneider was his favorite part of cir D
so
hilarious we go to bed and I mean in the
car the whole way home it's like 25
minutes away from the house he was just
like Hey Dad turn around one time I
swear to God he said hey Dad turn around
I turned around looked at him and he
said Rob
Schneider
bro he's not even four okay
so
so we get home yeah we go to
sleep
go to sleep we're all sleeping in the
same bed Billy is in another room but
it's me Kristen and Calvin is sleeping
in between us and where I'm playing
Royal match which by the way Calvin
showed me the game I didn't know about
it but I do play Royal match now it's an
app and I'm playing the game and
Calvin's like laughing messing it up and
[__] you know hitting the buttons and I
don't you know I I'm of two minds I'm
like ah it's beautiful I got to let my
kid do this this is so fun and I I can't
tell him to stop but then also I'm like
you're [__] up my Royal match game
you know
crazy I can't swallow that part and
completely have it leave my body but I'm
still in the back of my head I'm like a
he's ruining that all good well like why
do I even have to feel that part you
know why can't I just be in love with my
son moving the jewels around and [__]
it up for me but I also that bothers me
but hey real is real and he speaks his
mind right he speak his mind so anyway
um we go to sleep we wake up and when I
wake up I'm looking at Calvin because
I'm obsessed with him and he wakes up
opens his eyes looks at me and he
says
wow and I and I didn't say anything and
he says you know what that sounds like
and I said what and he said
wneo
bro after that I realized well the day
is not going to get any better you know
like that's the absolute Pinnacle of the
day and that's fine but how [__]
funny is it being that's what I'm saying
being a dad dude [__] talking to my
friend the other day he was like maybe
I'll have kids I'm like
bro what the [__] does poooo with the
scent thing in my eye
mean don't
know nah something got in my eye
though New Year's Eve was fun we went to
um I was in Long Beach I did the show in
Long
Beach and drove to Hollywood on the way
a little bit of argument with Kristen
and then did a show in uh at uh in
Hollywood we buttoned up the argument
you know what is it about [__]
holidays were you just is it a
self-fulfilling prophecy because at this
point I'm like I know one thing's going
to happen in the holidays I'm going to
eat too much and I'm going to get an
argument with my my wife like that's
just what is that and I know you feel me
on this dude dudes and the women like
what is it about that it's not
particularly more stressful I mean
sometimes it is right like if you're
having everybody over on Christmas
you're like well something's going to go
on I'm going to snap be ready hey like
you know what I'm saying like you wake
up in the morning now sweetie
me first of all Merry
Christmas love you can't wait to give
you your gift I know the fam's coming
over later sweetheart I'm GNA snap okay
forgive me I'll try not to but it's
inevitable I'm gonna I'm gonna say
something really sharp to you right I'm
not going to call you a [__] because I
don't do
that but I'm going to hit you with the
business right I'm going to say well
then where the [__] is it louder than I
my normal Cadence right let's just I and
you're then you're going to be like I
okay and you're going to get quiet right
you quiet for way too
long and then I'm gonna have to come
over and be like what's up something
wrong and I know what's wrong but I'm
going to have to make you say
it
right
so you know New Year's happened so we I
don't even honestly remember what it was
about we buttoned it up it's all
good but my my my my uh but Kristen was
like I want to go after oh this so I
this is not what the argument was like I
was like hey I'm gonna do shows on on
New Year's Eve if you want to come if
you don't want to come I won't do the
shows right but like if and we'll go out
or whatever we'll stay home go whatever
it is something we'll do something else
but I'll do shows if you want to come
out she's like [__] Yeah sounds like fun
so I booked the shows did them and she
was like hey my friends are
at Soho House
downtown
um can we go after your set at the Laugh
Factory the second one and I was like
[__] man I'm supposed to go on stage at
10 1116 was my spot I'm going to do 20
minutes 25 35 36 that's how I do math so
it's going to be
11:36 then I got to get down to downtown
which is who the [__] I mean sometimes
that drive is an hour in traffic I don't
think there'll be that much traffic but
I'm like babe we may not make it because
here's the thing the spots are at 11:16
it's not going to be at 11:16 the spots
going to be later than that so we're
playing it real close and my my wife is
cool as [__] she goes like this who
cares and I'm like we might be in the
car when the ball drops and she says
whatever and I'm like you're
awesome but she really wants to go to
the so house and gun to my
head do I want to go to Soho
House G in my head like I'm trying to
think nah you know I don't gun to my
head do I want to
go do
anything nah you know what I'm saying I
wanna I want to go home
right don't want to be a new it's all
her friends fine her I love her friends
by the way but none of my friends which
they're my friends too but you know what
I mean dude don't make me explain
it um
and uh so the manager says when do you
want me to light you and I say h give me
a light at like 15 and then I'll wrap it
up in five you know five minutes or
whatever it is what how long spot is 18
minutes it's like all
right um on stage it's going well I'm
having a good time on stage um making
people laugh usually New Year's shows
are sometimes a little weird and
disjointed because anytime a show is
about when something else takes
precedence over the comedy the show is
not as good usually like New Year's Eve
comedy show the thing on everyone's mind
is it's New Year's Eve not the comedy
show or St Patrick's Day right anything
like that is just Halloween the worst
time to perform right so
um so but it was good so I did the show
and I'm on stage and I look and I get
the
light uh but it's not the light that
they usually give it's
the
[__] it's it's a cell phone with red
on it and I'm like oh the light must be
broken I get off
stage and my wife's like let's go
and I'm like all right we we may we got
17 minutes to get
downtown we get in a car and she was
like oh man I wonder if we'll make it it
says ETA is 12:01 so I'm like
[__] dude I'm in the throat mobile good
time I took it I took this bro I'm
screaming through the streets and my
wife was like wasn't that hilarious and
I said wasn't what hilarious and she
said when
I when I lit you
you
dude I didn't even get the light
yet my wife lit
me
dude my wife was in the back with her
cell phone
giving me the
light oh
dity I was like that was why the light
was not the light and it was a red cell
phone she was like yeah like I was going
to like it I actually did I thought it
was [__] hilarious she was like
because I knew you wanted the light I
heard you say you wanted at 15 minutes
and it was 15 minutes I was like they
were going to let me go longer she was
like yeah but I knew it was at 15
minutes and I looked at the the time we
get there and we we going to get there
in the nick of time so I L you I was you
got off just in time we're going to be
there 12:01 she was like try to shave 2
minutes off I was
like all right dude I'm screaming down
the 101 she's just like go faster by the
way she is always on my [__] if I didn't
think about texting and driving she's
like uh-uh if I don't do a stop at a
stop sign she's like
Christopher and
now when it benefits her dude she's like
go faster I'm like baby I'm going 90
miles an hour
faster I go faster she's hell yeah
dude we get there at 1158 your boy can
drive he's Mario andred he's aler Jr
what the [__] godamn it
dude screaming through the streets of
LA you know car's too low oh [__] God
damn it every time that happens my the
bottom I bottom out and also I bottom
out because my anus prolapses because
I'm so
nervous
um M and then dude here's the thing you
don't know my
wife but she did the most my wife thing
ever you don't know her so this isn't
going to
be this isn't going to be anger inducing
to you guys but for me it's going to be
anger
inducing we're driving on the way there
halfway there I'm screaming going 90 on
the
freeway it's a Tupac song
and she says oh
[Laughter]
[__] and I say what and she says I don't
have my wallet
it
hey this
sucks a a come on
wife you left your wallet home on New
Year's Eve oh hey come on I guess we got
to go to the Brain
Store you need a replacement
so
dude I and I'm like oh babe we're not
going to be able to get in and she says
nah I'm going to get my friend to come
down and meet
us give me her ID and then we're going
to get in with her ID and I say what the
[__] is your friend going to do she's
like she's already in there she already
got in so it'll be fine I'm like maybe
and then I actually say this maybe they
won't card us because it's me
like a [__] degenerate but if it's
good for
something because know sometimes they
like oh yeah yeah come on in you know
cuz you're famous
so I get
there I pull up I say bro uh here's the
keys I do the
valet the guy of course her friend isn't
out there so I'm like the bouncer the
you know he's French or some [__] he's
like no no I'm I'm pulling up my wife is
already there talk to the bouncer
bouncer and she's just like I don't know
yeah so what is it with the uh to me
looking to me like that that look of oh
hey we're GNA talk a secret language and
you're going to be on my page right and
we're gonna outsmart this guy and I see
it in her face and I I and I think oh
[__] what page right because like are we
spies cuz if we're spies cool but also
you had some shots so it's not going to
probably go the way you think it so
she's like so are we on is it was it was
it Patty's list or and I'm and I'm like
well Patty's her friend but she was like
are you on is it you that has the
membership or is it Patty that has the
membership and I'm like well I don't
have a membership to Soh house so I have
to say Patty so I'm like Patty and then
the French bouncer's like then we need
both of your IDs and I'm just
like where's your
friend like what page do I how am I so
then Patty runs and time we're the buzz
is up you know New Year's is
happening there's there's 30 Seconds To
Midnight
okay Patty comes down that's them the
French guy looks at me and goes okay go
ahead we go in we're in the elevator and
we're like is it time we're in the
elevator in the elevator with it's the
it's three of us and then one other
chick that we don't know and she's like
I think the ball is dropping and we're
like okay we go up to the oh the door
go the the elevator doors go Bo and
everyone SCS happy New Year dude and we
[__] made it
that was the best way dude we did it he
screamed through the 101 and [__]
valet parked his car which he doesn't
normally valet that car because it's
[__] high-end but he still did it
Patty came down didn't need the [__]
IDs went up in the elevator doors open
screamed happy New Year [__] yeah dude
it was so dope and then Al since after
that the night obviously went downhill
because that was really exciting and
then I was just kind of like buying
drinks for
everybody how crazy is it that when it's
like your wife or your girl and her
friends and like you you're paying for
the drinks and I know everybody doesn't
do this
but like you're just you're
paying
for a worst
time you
know it's like
you're you're it's the worst
transaction everything you pay for
benefits you cuz money benefits you and
with money you get stuff that the only
thing you get is something that benefits
you nobody's going to be like hey here's
10K give me
HIV right but when you're with your wife
or girlfriend and her friend friends and
you're buying the drinks even if you're
just buying them some
drinks you're paying to make it worse
for
you that and I'm here I am babe the card
and I'm just oh here
uh okay what what is
it you know oh you already added the tip
gr I did I also tipped so that's that
just way too much here you go and then
um okay drink all these ladies and then
yell at my
face drink all these and then you know
dance
to don't forget to scream out the part
we want prenups when they play it
right and
uh
so I'm like all right and they're having
a blast and by the way I'm
joking it was it was it was they were
having a great time and it was really
cool to to see like I was obviously
sober not not drinking but they were
having a few drinks and it was it was so
fun to see them have fun like and I'm
just like it was one of those things
like you know we were having
conversation but then I was like they
were dancing on the dance floor and I'm
like huh I'm an appendix right now I'm
not
needed
right I could literally
explode and it would be okay you know
appendix can just burst and like you can
just get it out you don't need
it
so I'm like I'm going to go out to the
uh outside area cuz it looks like
there's less people
there and I walk out there and this dude
looks at me and he says bro
oh 12 out of 10 you're a 12 out of
10 and I'm
like is he talking about my comedy or is
this guy trying to [__] me like I don't
know what he's
means so I say you're the man
bro fist bump him then I go sit down in
water of course because that's just what
happens I sat down on a wet spot because
it was time for that you know what I'm
saying I didn't want to I didn't know
there was a wet I knew it was there I
wouldn't have sat there but it was my
time in the night and in my life to sit
on a wet spot and be annoyed for the
rest of the night cuz I had a wet ass
right I it should it was just I didn't
even get mad at I sat in the wet spot
and in my head i' just go that's the
game and I sit down I go charge it to
the game that is the just yes that's how
it goes the cookie crumbles that way
great
fine um I'm in the wet spot cuz I ain't
moving I'm Bez at this point I ain't
moving
and because I'm stubborn and if I'm
going to sit in a wet spot I'm gonna I'm
going
to work it out like I heard George
Carlin once say that he got a jay
walking ticket and so since then he
started to J walk even more and in a few
years he worked out to like each jwalk
was a fraction of a
penny and I'm like I'm going to store
that in my mind and then that's why I
sat in the wet spot and didn't move
because I'm like I'm going to make this
worth it I'm not going to use the energy
to get up and get to a different dry
spot and then [__] it right so I'm like
ah wet spot all right cool charge the
game I'm all good so I sit there and
because I'm not getting up dude all this
is this [__] that goes on in my mind bro
bro I I
mean when I say this out loud sometimes
on the podcast I'm just like I can't
believe how crazy I
am and I'm
on
meds like I'm on
meds like people people out there that
are afraid to take meds because they
think they're going to change who you
are hey take the meds it's going to be
fine I sat in a wet spot on purpose for
15 minutes you're
good
so I'm sitting there this dude comes up
to me a different dude not the 12 out of
10 dude and
says dude he does one of
these and it's fine except for
he already did that 10 minutes ago to me
didn't tell you that part because I
wanted to tell the story like this
because I wanted you to understand how
annoying it was after I threw that in
there okay I didn't tell you about the
guy
before when he did it because then I
didn't want to be like and then that guy
who did this came along and then did
this again it wouldn't have had as much
impact
as you know I did like the Pulp Fiction
thing where it was like oh it starts in
the middle and it ends at the beginning
and
[__] it would have been f one of these
is
fine bro again you did it inside and
outside
so you know oh yeah what's up he says
man what's up dude I'm like not much
just chilling you're the man
and he says yeah do hey do you mind if I
sit down and just have a chat with you
and I go in my
[Music]
head right the alarms like how the [__]
do I get out of this but I say a version
of hell
yes because I don't want to be a dick
what you know what I mean like have
boundaries I and then I through the
whole course of conversation I'm talking
to this guy for like 5 minutes 6 minutes
I'm like I could have just said I'm
actually enjoying sitting in this wet
spot by myself
sir
um but he was like so dude like you know
what he said to me at first so how's
comedy hey guy
are you taking boring
pills what the
[__] hey guy come on hey guy can you
sign up for some conversation
class I know it sounds [__] an like
I'm an elitist and [__] but
like come with it man how's comedy you
know what I'm going to say
good it's good man I don't know what do
you mean you know it's good yeah how
Show's been great man it's been going
really well you know torn a lot
yeah yeah hey man can I ask you
something he says and I say in my
head but obviously hell
[Laughter]
yes and he says got a
question what's your favorite City to
perform
in and the truth is I don't know people
ask me that a lot but
like it's kind of
all the
same except for when you're in
like
Sugarland
Texas you
know
or de Mo I I you know I don't
know but I whenever say what's your
favorite city of Performing because that
that's that's not what's your favorite
City to be in that that is an easy
answer question oh I love New York I
love uh you know uh
Vancouver Toronto Austin I love these
Chicago my kind of town
right
um but what's your fav performing now I
got to think of the shows okay I go I go
I was like I don't know Boston is great
to perform in uh Chicago New York Fort
Lauderdale is really great and I'm and
he's like
huh and uh and I was like maybe
at least the silver lining of this
conversation will be because it wasn't
that bad the guy was so nice and I'm
being funny for the podcast
but at least I know one thing that is
keeping me going in this
conversation his ass is probably
wet so I'm talking to him and he's
trying to pretend his ass isn't wet but
I know we're both in the wet ass
Club
right I know I know as soon as you sat
down that we're both sitting in we're
swamp asses right now and then he says
all right well good to you know we
talked for six minutes oh oh and then
the 12 out of 10 guy comes
up and says hey man here's a drink to me
and I'm like oh dude I don't drink I'm
really sorry but uh you know I I don't
and she says all right gives it to the
other guy and says here you drink it and
the guy's like uh he didn't know the guy
and I'm like bro no you know what I
mean takes a drink the guy leaves then
the guy who was talking to me got up and
I looked down completely dry in his area
and I was
[Music]
pissed I was the only one with swamp
pass charge it to the
game dude I can't believe chrisan light
lit me you know that's like absolutely
Bonkers but it is what it is God that's
funny
dude that's
funny I can't wait till my Sacramento
shows how about
that um Sacramento I kind of I like
performing in Sacramento I know it's
kind of a people think it's a kind of a
weird town but it's nice it's not I'm
not the I'm not saying the the thing is
not n the the town is nice I don't
know what is this this is crazy that you
sent me this Ian zering fights mini
bikers on new y's Eve because I I
[__] thought of Ian oh Ian I thought
hison I thought of him today bro what
the
[__] the last time I thought of ion
zering before
today was when I was
13 and I thought of him today and I
actually thought oh yeah that's a guy by
the way I've met him a few
times the nicest bro when I tell you
when somebody says who's the nicest guy
you met in Hollywood he's at the top of
the
list John Corbett is at the top of the
list and Ian zering is at the top of the
list who else is at the top of the list
the nicest guys in Hollywood um
ion zering John cor
Corbett
uh a lot of dicks in Hollywood
honestly a lot of dicks in
Hollywood
um that's
it if there was a movie with John
Corbett and ion
zering I would be first in line I would
be there before the the theater opened
up dressed as one of their characters
like they do for Star
Wars that that's how nice they are
they're both so nice who the [__] else
is
nice I don't know I can't think of
another nice person and I don't mean not
like I know nice people in Hollywood but
I'm talking about that nice where you
just walk away and you're like God damn
he was really nice and made me feel
really comfortable you know a lot of
people are are you know cool [__] anyway
um this is the video where he got now
now I have a video of him getting in a
fight with bikers so it was probably
because he was like trying to save a
woman that's how nice he
is and we are following some developing
news Beverly Hills 90210 star Ian zering
attacked by a group of bikers in La holy
[__] video from TMZ shows the New Year's
Eve dust up along Hollywood Boulevard as
several mini bikes were zipping in and
out of traffic it appears Z Zing's car
may have been hit and he took out his
anger on one of the bikers others joined
in ganging up on zering until he ran
across the street to break free TMZ
reports a police report was taken
listing zering as the
victim dude that's crazy they're like
and this is for Brenda dude how crazy is
it
you know what sucks
dude having to get into a fight with a
guy with four guys with helmets on you
just you can't punch them you break your
hand so you just go ah
[__] man must that you know what that is
straight up rage some ion zering
rage this is
crazy that's it I'm going to be in
Sacramento and Houston and uh Phoenix
and Albuquerque and El Paso go to to
chia.com to get tickets and after this
go watch my special chris.com it's
called grow or die get at chris.com
appreciate the support work really hard
on it and then uh leave a comment and
all that if you want to watch uh that's
it for YouTube if you want to watch the
rest of the video uh uh this episode go
to patreon.com christalia and watch uh
watch the rest of it this uh and watch
the rest of every other episode that we
have and then also watch the one episode
a month that we do extra on our patreon
for just $6 I don't even know how many
episodes there are but you can go get it
now and watch all of the ones that we've
done if you're on a road trip if you're
having a good time if you want to
[__] B do it but thank you very much
you guys we
[Music]
out